[Music]
hello I'm Kemal Santamaria this is
counting the cost on al-jazeera
your weekly look at the world of
business and economics this week India
15 of the most polluted cities in the
world are on the subcontinent we take a
look at the health costs to one of the
world's fastest growing economies also
already under pressure from a trade war
now the anti-government protests could
plunge Hong Kong's economy into
recession reporting from the LA photon
islands in Arctic Norway or an area rich
in biodiversity but also in the
crosshairs the big oil companies hello
everybody this week's a little different
on counting the cost we've let our
correspondents and documentary makers
loose on a number of important economic
stories big-picture stuff and given them
a bit more time to do so and we are
starting with what has become the
world's most polluted capital city in
according to the World Health
Organization and Greenpeace that city is
New Delhi in fact 15 of the 20 most
polluted cities in the world are in
India alone clearly it can't be good for
people's health but how does it impact
the country and its economy now 2-0
documentary Megan Neha Tara Mehta has
this feature report like many parents in
Delhi
dr. shell intrepid Oriya knows that
allowing his children to play outdoors
comes at a cost your pollution is
affecting our life on day to day basis
was I moved to this place I started
developing Ostmark and next few years he
became really worse sometimes I have to
come in the middle of the night to the
ICU even my daughter who was just one
month old she also used to get osmotics
dr. podila lives on one of the most
polluted parts of the city and believes
the air quality is made worse by
emissions from a waste-to-energy plant
in his neighborhood there's high level
of pollution Delhi and the top of that
the
plant so definitely even in Delhi if you
are staying one place other place
there's a difference as a doctor he
knows only too well that air pollution
can have lasting consequences on his
family's health with the time you might
have a big long week excise capacity I
cannot continue my exercise capacity
exercise for very long period because
after a few days I get either cough cold
asthma anything the plant management
refused to respond to our query on its
health impact but one of its top
officials said in a whatsapp message
that the plants performance met all
operating parameters and is well within
prescribed limits over a million Indians
died in 2017 because of air pollution
according to the global burden of
disease study but the Indian government
has consistently maintained there is no
direct correlation between air pollution
and deaths there are multiple causes of
mortality how do you pinpoint that air
quality is the cause it can be a trigger
it certainly is a trigger in most of the
cases but I think if you continue to do
Studies on this and come up with
conclusive data it helps but an
increasing number of doctors say there
is a clear link between air pollution
and deaths there is enough data
available that air pollution kills
science must continue but action should
not evade the results of scientific
studies because that may take 10 20
years and by that time they would have
lost millions of people unnecessarily to
this menace air pollution has been
linked to a third of all lung cancer
deaths in India one of its victims was
Priyanka Chen a digital marketing
consultant based in Delhi she was
diagnosed almost overnight with stage 4
lung cancer the right lung is completely
damaged and
the cancer has spread so much that it's
just not visible on this x-ray when we
met her in April this year she blamed
the city's dirty air for her illness I
don't foresee any other reason for lung
cancer to happen to me otherwise
breathing is the most important practice
that you're doing every moment and
that's your source of life so the air
that you're breathing if that is poor
that definitely is a significant
contributor for any respiratory disease
her doctor also believed that air
pollution could have led to her terminal
illness there's enough evidence in the
world that pollution can do that and I
really wonder if that was the main
contributory factor in her case Priyanka
lost her battle to cancer in July 2019
less than four months after we'd
interviewed her she had just turned 27
and it's not just the health of people
that's being affected by air pollution
it also affects the health of the
economy if you add up the number of
years we are losing because of illness
because of the productive time and you
know what this is coming at huge
economic cost
India is one of the world's
fastest-growing economies and even
though its growth has slowed down it
aims to be worth five trillion dollars
over the next few years but according to
the World Bank the country lost over 8%
of its GDP in 2013 because the fair
pollution and latest research from the
Indian Statistical Institute shows that
reducing pollution would help the
country gain billions we could cut air
pollution to zero every Indian would be
willing to pay about $300 per year to
cut that risk the total benefit would be
about three or four hundred billion
dollars per year which is about 10 to 15
percent of total income in India air
pollution has dominated the headlines in
the country for a few years now even
moving major political parties to
include it in their manifestos the
government is making a push for clean
energy and electric vehicles among other
measures earlier this year it launched
the first national clean air program
that aims to bring down air pollution in
more than a hundred cities over the next
five years but some experts think the
program needs more teeth any target
without clear compliance and
accountability mechanism does not work
so the current approach that will
collaborate cooperate find friendly
answers that is not really going to
bring the kind of push that we require
to make things happen on ground and with
studies indicating that nearly 700
million Indians are exposed to polluted
air there's little time to lose if we
were to freeze all the legislation and
do nothing now onwards in 2050 roughly
930 million people or half the
population in 2050 would still be
exposed to air which exceeds our ambient
air quality standards Ratna Bora of
cleaner Asia says there are lessons to
be learned from how India's neighbor
China has battled its notoriously high
air pollution levels China puts air
pollution not as part of an environment
of the agenda it's part of national
planning process so obviously it's an
economic agenda in countries like ours
where we are looking at rapid
development we're looking at you know
energy transition we are looking at
things like smart cities we definitely
need to integrate air within within
development policy industrial pollution
remains a serious challenge but
businesses are beginning to step up say
Seema Arora of the Confederation of
Indian Industry
well industry realizes that we do cause
a bit of this problem a lot of them are
coming up and saying how can I be a part
of the solution and this change we only
see in the last one year actually the
government is betting big on moving to
cleaner vehicle emission standards in
2020 but this hasn't come without
challenges for the auto industry which
is already struggling with some of the
worst sales figures in recent years the
time given to us was extremely small in
three years time we are supposed to dip
from and internationally countries have
taken anything between eight to ten
years to do this kind of work
meanwhile citizens are opting for
private solutions to a public problem
this kamas tells us that is sales of
breathing apparatus have been booming
easier time masks and nebulizers are
going to become compulsory in the time
to come every home will need to stock up
on them and this building in a busy
South Delhi neighborhood seems to offer
pollution free office space PM 2.5 a
highly dangerous particle that is 30
times smaller than the width of human
hair is almost absent from here so we're
right outside one of the area's greenest
buildings and the PM 2.5 levels here
have been hovering at about a hundred
which is about twice of India's daily
national standard and about four times
out of the international standard let's
go and see what the building is doing
now to clean up its air entrepreneur
Varun Agarwal shows
the plants and technology that keep
pollutants out the mechanical filtration
takes care of the particulate matter and
some of the harmful outdoor gases that
when you bring outdoor air there are the
gases as well that takes care of it but
as the plants help in reducing the
indoor pollutants ie the volatile
organic compounds and the PM 2.5 levels
have actually come down to 14 from about
a hundred outside that's a difference
that the air purification process makes
over here Haroon also has a warehouse
stocked with air purifiers that cost
between four hundred to two thousand
dollars a hefty price tag for most
Indians is it elitist yes it is but if I
can't afford it if I can help my kids
and my family breathe better air and
help them protect their lungs I'm gonna
do everything I can and ask for dr.
Padilla the line between his hospital
and home has blurred because of his
daughter Nandini's frequent asthama
attacks and unless the city's pollution
is brought under control soon dr. Midori
majors joined the growing ranks of
highly skilled professionals leaving the
city not for greener pastures
but for cleaner air al-jazeera's najara
Mehta with that in sight and you can see
more of her work and that of our
documentary makers online at around 2 0
dot com slash people and power or have a
look in the documentaries menu and now
to Hong Kong you've seen the protests
there you've seen the depth of feeling
but the territories finance chief is now
warm the economy could be plunged into
recession
if the anti-government protests continue
one citywide strike cost the economy as
much as three hundred and thirty-two
million dollars according to economists
and don't forget the knock-on effect -
from the trade war between the United
States and China and Joe Thomas has been
reporting for al-jazeera right
throughout the protest movement here is
his take on the economic effect
monsoons during Hong Kong's rainy season
often put a dampener on shopping but
this year it's not just the rain
[Music]
protests against Hong Kong's government
are having a big impact on the retail
sector
[Music]
retail revenues in June were down seven
percent year-on-year
figures per July and August are expected
to show drops between ten and twenty
percent this locksmith in Central Hong
Kong
says in 42 years it's never been so bad
business is terrible terrible people
have lost the desire to spend I hope
both sides can resolve the conflict soon
so to stop hurting the economy and free
us from worry and fear tourists to are
missing especially those from mainland
China hotel occupancy rates in June as
the protests began were three percent
down or normal July's figures once
they're out will show much steeper fall
still these are those who weren't put
off this time around but for some it was
a close call mainlanders like us afraid
to run into protests I won't be rushing
back I rather wait until it all tightens
down it worried me when I heard about
the demonstrations before I came since
I've been here it's actually been fine
peaceful there's been no sign of
demonstrations in the places I've been
tourists losing confidence in Hong Kong
is one thing but if international credit
rating agencies do too that could be
disastrous if the poll tests continue
and escalate and become uncontrollable
then that will have significant impact
on Hong Kong's okay ready waiting and
there will be huge
okay likely to be impact Hong Kong's
current credit rating scores are similar
to those of the United States there are
a lot better than mainland China's
because Hong Kong is seen as
economically and legally independent the
protests could mean a downgrade either
because they make Hong Kong a more
difficult place to do business or
because evidence of Beijing asserting
its authority would undermine the
independence that many consider makes
Hong Kong special
the cost of doing business will be high
and that will have impact on their
profit
already Hong Kong's economy was sluggish
way down by the us-china trade war April
to June figures show annual growth of
just naught point six percent well down
on a year ago and then there is housing
prices dropped almost one percent in
June with much bigger falls expected
properties and moveable si and you can't
escape from the impair of the political
instability so not many people are going
to enter the market in this kind of
situation
Robert II sale volumes in July were at
their lowest level of the year many
analysts expect property prices here to
fall 10 percent by the end of the year
although those working in property say
2014's Occupy movement was expected to
hit prices - but it didn't end up
putting off investors from the mainland
the impact of these protests could be
similarly small 2019 - protests though
have already been the most widespread
Hong Kong has ever seen the city is
known for economic stability and success
but its success depends on its stability
and finally some in-depth environmental
reporting because if you want to count
the cost then the cost to our planet is
arguably the most important one now for
decades Norway has been smart it's saved
money from the sale of its oil and gas
and in doing so created actually the
world's biggest sovereign wealth fund
today worth a trillion dollars but now
are recognizing the damage done to our
climate from the use of hydrocarbons the
funder started to sell its holdings in
oil and gas and is actually leaving oil
worth billions of dollars under the
ground our environment editor at Al
Jazeera's of course Nick Clark here he
is with a multi-layered report looking
at how climate change is shaping the
landscape of Norway's shipping fishing
and oil industries the far north of
Norway is spectacular the land of
mountains and fjords and raw beauty it's
an important fishing area and as you can
imagine it brings in the tourist dollar
this is actually the highest mountain
level particularly in the Lofoten
Islands we're getting up close to nature
is what you do the problem is the
welfare also lies beneath the waters for
a long time the Lofoten Islands have
been in the crosshairs of the big oil
companies because their geologists know
that in these coastal waters lies an
untapped oil field worth an estimated 60
billion dollars and their bosses want a
license to explore in the past this has
been supported by the government and for
many it's a big concern as I said I'm
all against oil but I'm also
really afraid of the damages that can
happen if there isn't big always bills I
wouldn't take the risk but things may be
changing recently Norway's opposition
Labour Party withdrew its support for
Lofoten exploration meaning now there's
a majority in parliament to keep the
islands off limits the young people
today and they are more important about
the future climate change what you
really believe about and I think the
fisheries and the tourism industry is
the future more than oil and gas
especially in this this arctic areas
Norway is a nation made rich by four
decades of oil and gas extraction with
the sovereign wealth fund worth a
colossal one trillion dollars so any
move away from fossil fuels is
significant the climate crisis is also
more real it's closed up in our face you
have to do serious stuff the next 10
years
uneducated people in Norway understand
that even we start to understand that
there will be some changes and it's not
even maybe politically decided that the
market will change the demand of
consumers will demand and we are happy
without making progress but for those in
la virgen who rely on these waters and
fear the potential impact of oil spills
there's still skepticism but we never
get the fully fully know for oil
exploitation so for me it seems like
it's only know until it's yes and when
it's yes there's no turning back at a
time when the world needs to radically
cut back on fossil fuel emissions it
will become increasingly hard for the
nation to justify new extraction
contracts especially in these waters
this is what made Norway rich long
before oil Arctic cod or scray in their
millions fill drying racks across the
Lofoten Islands winter after winter
fishermen here have cashed in on the
annual migration south from the Barents
Sea it is a tradition that goes back
thousands of years
the cod is caught it's gutted and then
it's held out to dry for several months
and what you end up with is a dry
fish that retains nearly 100% of its
nutrition a prized delicacy from Italy
to Nigeria this is what supplied the
Vikings on their long voyages to far-off
lands and still now is a big part of the
Norwegian economy worth millions of
dollars the fish comes from the barren
sea and its goals to look for to spawn
and that because of that land extreme to
the left extreme it stops by local and
brings food it brings some higher
temperature even though it's not warm
but it's high high enough to spawn and
it's a very delicate ecosystem in local
that fragility is spelt out by a ream of
scientific research as a changing
climate and warmer ocean temperatures
upset the balance of the marine
ecosystem
meaning the scray may be forced out and
then it's a question of where they go
obviously if keeps things keep warming
some of those true polar species might
and not having a whole lot of places to
go if they're being out competed by sort
of these more southern species moving
north third we can see you might see
some considerable changes there this
year GERD Nielsen caught 13 thousand
kilos of cod it's been a pretty good
season but he's worried about the future
climate change could change everything
the code can suddenly stop coming to
look for them because it'd be warmer and
going a longer and longer North so then
we have a big problem every year is
spring comes the cod leave their return
has always been a certainty and a
necessity not just for the fishermen but
for the seals sea birds and whales that
feed on them now this extraordinary feat
of nature is under threat and the
outcome as ever depends on the political
will to act in a time of global crisis
the clevon yards on the west coast of
norway where there's been a long rich
history of shipbuilding but this is
something different
two ships the Roald Amundsen and the
fritz often Anson are nearing completion
and they're a step into the future both
these vessels are state-of-the-art
expedition ships it will take paying
passengers to remote parts of the world
powered partly by battering putting a
new expedition ship together is a
complex process as you might imagine
involving welders carpenters and
plumbers and of course electricians
there's more than 750 kilometers of
cabling to say nothing of detailed and
extensive wiring for powering the ship
by self generated electricity the
batteries aren't in place yet so what
what are we what's going to be put in
place here and what will we see and this
rack your can can fit 20 and battery
cells it will be about thousand Walt
for each cell or each rack here with
this Rex which we have behind us now we
can reduce the 20% of the fuel
consumption of the ship the vessels
thrust will come from a combination of
diesel and battery power the batteries
themselves will be constantly charged by
the ship's engines as they run Kyle
Bryson will be captain on the Roald
Amundsen as she attempts the Northwest
Passage later this year it's really
important because we are am going to
remote areas horrible areas and to be
able to do no footprints but yeah
footprints that we will give its only
the green footprints we supply the power
system with the batteries as we are
sailing but also when we do the
operation in Arctic Arctic and
Antarctica given the shipping industry
is responsible for a significant
proportion of the global climate problem
change cannot come soon enough
ultimately the dream is of a ship with
no need of a funnel hybrid and and
reducing consumption is one thing but
even more interesting I think is the
work that is now going into fully
electric
shipping we've seen some initiatives on
that as well in Norway and that's an
area where Norwegian the Norwegian
shipping industry might get an advantage
as an early adopter electric ferries can
already be seen in some of the world's
ports while on shore power and others
enables vessels to be plugged in so
engines can be switched off
while docked and Hurtigruten and now
planning to convert several ships like
the nordkapp here to run on a
combination of fuel including biogas
made from organic wastes like timber and
dead fish with the day when the mega
ships of the world are powered solely by
renewable energy while that is still in
the distant future and that is our show
for this week but we'd love to hear from
you can tweet or message me directly I'm
at Kemal hae do use the hashtag at AJ
CTC when you do or drop us an email
can't in the cost to down to zero net is
the address and you can visit us online
as well aljazeera.com slash CTC that'll
take you straight to our page with
individual reports links and entire
episodes for you to catch up one but
that is it for this edition of counting
the cost I'm Kemal santamaría from the
whole team thanks for joining us the
news on al Jazeera is next
[Music]